hey guys what's up this is andrew for
twinsenses.com
so as many of you have asked me this
week
to make this kind of update i'm here to
make an analysis
on bbby and blackberry so let's see what
are my targets
and what are the chats telling us let's
get into it
[Music]
alright guys so i've never made any
updates on
blackberry so this is my first one so
just very quickly the first thing i do
so i think this is interesting for you
you can
you know do it on a daily timeframe and
here guys remember that this kind of
technique
here i connect the high here and here
and it gives me my breakout level my
retest level so
if i was with you guys here and i'm
sorry
i didn't make this kind of update but
here guys i mean it's
a very obvious buying level and
then we had this strong move up in
january since then
we are just correcting but guys where
are we in terms of wave development
i'm gonna do this with you guys for the
first time
all right so this is what is playing out
okay guys i almost guarantee that we're
gonna have
this the reason behind is that this is
just fitting well
all right so i'm here doing some idiot
wave counting with you guys
this is a zigzag and as usual guys for
those who are watching my video you know
that when you have
here flat b c flat
then you're gonna have a zigzag in the
fourth wave those two
there like to you know switch so zigzag
flat or flat
zigzag here it was flat zigzag all right
so we had the one we had the two we had
the three
we completed the four and here guys let
me now
zoom in let's go into hourly time frame
and see what we're having
then i'm gonna give you the targets that
you are waiting for don't worry
it's coming and let's analyze this
wave quickly so one two
either it's three four five and then
it's a one
and then it's one two three four five
all right i think this is the most
likely scenario
so i'm gonna keep it this way
okay this is what is gonna happen guys i
think this is what is going to happen
up up up now how do i find my targets i
measure first wave applied to the bottom
of the second wave that i don't know yet
bam then we usually
retrace here depending where it's going
to be the wave development
we might do something like this so this
is what is probably going to happen
and once again i want to give you
this is very hypothetical i'm not sure
about that but
what i'm more convinced of
is this up
okay
one two so i measured the third wave
here and applied to the bottom of the
fourth wave but this time guys i have
the button all right
so here i was a bit maybe too bullish
okay so we're gonna have something like
this so different scenarios guys
different scenarios we might go
here so the most likely one is the 1.618
so 42 guys
if you're expecting a higher level i'm
sorry
but i don't think you will see it right
away
42 is a very nice target we might also
go to 63 that's possible but less
likely i think that
another thing that can happen is that
this wave is extended and that the third
wave
actually goes here so this is another
scenario and that we do a four and five
like this all right so then we would go
here
so we need to see actually where this
third wave is gonna go
but if the third wave is only gonna go
here then
uh probably the fifth wave is only gonna
go here and then we're gonna have this
five wave development that is complete
all right so this is much less
bullish bullish than amc gamestop i
don't see the same potential here
definitely
but i see a very nice move up to come
because here we are talking about
guys it's now at 13
right 200 percent guys that's serious
right
that's serious uh let me give you
maybe more information where
this is going to correct because you
might want to enter this trade
so as usual guys we use fibs we use
trend lines
so films are telling us 13 12
other levels to buy all right 12.2 13.7
this is coming from fibs this is the
levels to buy
trend lines are going to give us this is
here
the 13 is a nice level and then
as usual guys the top of the third wave
so it's important to know if this is
complete or not
is the third wave coming here or here
you know
i'm not sure it's maybe more like this
so
the bottom of the force wave so i would
see actually for the
bottom of the second wave 12
6.6 guys this is my level 12.6 and from
then
we gonna go higher and in terms of
timing i would say one week
right one week before we make another
move up now
bby
no drawings okay i'm surprised this is a
stock i did many times
i mean at least i did it one time long
time ago guys so let me update
you here okay so
the first thing we check is
where is the breakout level okay the
breakout level is here guys
but as usual guys log scale don't forget
and you connect
the highs all right and there you guys
it's working
very well so i probably gave you this
levels guys you can go and check my
videos
i probably gave you this levels and told
you that we are bullish from here
and you can see breakout retested
retested retested and bam we go higher
now in terms of wave development where
are we
one two one two three four five three
four and five okay so for the same
reasons
i'm having here a fifth wave coming 200
moving average coming here
so this was a nice level to buy and now
in terms of
target as usual you measure the third
wave
then you apply to the bottom of the
force wave and it gives me
98 so this is my target i think we're
going to go to 98 within you know a few
months
or something like this and in terms of
level to buy so 98 is my target guys
in terms of levels as usual fibs
so you measure this the retracement
levels so
30 is a nice level to buy so we are
already below
i know we are above now so 30 and 24
are nice levels to buy but we might not
see 24 again
and in terms of trend lines
i'm looking for highs lows and
consolidation so here
i have a high so 26 is a nice level and
this one as well
okay so again so this whole area guys
so i'm the buyer here in this whole area
uh here i can zoom in
a little bit and do the same exercise
all right so here okay 30
all right so 20 is a nice level to buy
here having the 50
moving average coming here so all this
area guys let me
unzoom okay so i showed you here very
quickly
how i find my entry levels how i find my
targets
why i am bullish i need to find five
ways it moves up
once i have a breakout confirmed here
it's the case
so i'm very bullish on bbby on
blackberry as well
on gme and amc as well so that's it for
me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're gonna be the
first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys